j'espère sincèrement que tous les gens
qui ont la chance d'avoir le vaccin
j'encourage tout le monde à y aller les
vedettes peuvent influencer nos
comportements et c'est vrai aussi qu'on
vient le temps de convaincre les gens de
respecter les mesures sanitaires ou de
se faire vacciner partout sur la planète
des stars ont publié des esgaulx
portrait pour montrer qu'il soutient la
campagne de vaccination en france 200
personnalités ont signé une lettre
ouverte pour inciter les gens se faire
vacciner et au québec émile bilodeau a
même offert un concert surprise dans un
centre de vaccination
mais d'autres au contraire sont plus
sceptiques c'est le cas d'eric clapton
evans morrison qui ont fait paraître une
chanson anti protocole sanitaire la
chanson
et dans les paroles c'est assez
surprenant parce que ça dit carrément
veux tu être un esclave eric clapton
s'oppose également l'obligation de se
faire vacciner il a été critiqué à
plusieurs reprises et il a même dit
qu'il ne jouerait pas sur des scènes où
il y aurait un public discriminés et
donc lui les gens qui ne veulent pas se
faire vacciner ou les gens qui sont anti
passeport sanitaires il trouve que ce
sont des gens qui sont discriminés
j
une position qui n'a pas manqué de faire
réagir brian may le guitariste du groupe
queen qui le vertement critiqué second
france le rappeur akhenaton du groupe
iam s'est aussi exprimée contre le passé
ni terre avec le groupe iam nous sommes
contre le push pour chanteur lui il l'a
attrapé l'aco vide et il a été
hospitalisée pour détresse respiratoire
il est resté quand même à l'hôpital
quelques jours y est sorti il prend du
mieux
qu'ils soient pour ou contre les
artistes peuvent avoir un impact mais on
n'est pas que limiter la prise de
position d'artiste de joie ou de gens
très connus savoir renforçait une
décision qui est déjà prise dans un sens
ni dans l'autre par contre c'est très
peu probable que ça va faire changer
d'idée ous avons convaincu une personne
qui était très réfractaire par exemple à
sion à vacciner les vedettes font partie
de la société donc pas étonnant que dans
la colonie artistique aussi les avis
divergent ici nabi alexandre chartier
radio canada montréal